good morning John John Arun that time
when I use a green screen out of blue
construction paper obviously I'm enough
living in it sensation that I've just
take several pieces of blue construction
paper behind me so I could do blue
screen stuff yeah I'm still kind of
uncomfortable in here Tommy I go home
home we may notice that there's a thing
down here talking about what I'm talking
about right now which is weird right
that's because today's video comes to
you in 27 parts and I asked people on
Twitter last night and they came through
like this person who's wondering where
my inspiration comes from well obviously
it comes from you I was editing my be
Giants show in Spokane this weekend and
opening for them was the great Jonathan
Coulton at the beginning of his set he
was talking about how he signed all the
pre-orders of his CDs he joked about how
though it was hard he didn't have to
sign 150,000 or anything which I think
it's probably a reference to the Fault
in Our Stars which is pretty cool John
and I are starting big new channels on
YouTube but one that I'm doing called
youtube.com slash sighs all the
general are gonna be talking about the
news and science and also broader topics
so that we can all just be smarter
t-shirt and jeans right does it mean
anything people who know then I try
my clothes our breath as people smell
bad because bacteria that live in our
mouth I don't find the conversation
about whether video games are art to be
particularly interesting requires there
to be a definition of art that everyone
in the world will accept and I don't
accept that precept on 11/11/11 or to
love and love it I'm thinking maybe I'd
out doing a live show I don't know come
back here then and see because I just
want to see Dimpy Giants I've been
listening to the new album join us like
constantly yes there is love and
marriage I don't know what WAP is but
your teachers full of crap I hear this a
lot that microwaves destroy all the
nutrients in food and I just have to say
that that's not true when microwave
doesn't do anything that steaming or
frying wouldn't do it in fact boiling is
much worse at decreasing the nutrient
content of vegetables and started
selling Morningstar vetted corndogs
again in my grocery drawer this is
extremely exciting for me stupid Twitter
Oh No why I'm not good actually thought
about doing NaNoWriMo this year and then
I realized that it's like halfway
through November already every year in
New York Harry Potter fans get together
and they play the actual game of actual
Quidditch or an actual Quidditch pitch
and it's happening this weekend and if
you are around you should go there's
more information in the description I
think mine crossed totally amazing I
just found a really cool place to build
my new house all this gold right there
or or right there that's awesome what is
that I'm just gonna hey I somehow
survived that somehow surrender not
anymore a little while ago I made a
video about how is not gonna eat meat
for a month and then I didn't talk about
it ever again and that's not because I
didn't not eat meat for a month it's
just cuz I didn't talk about it again
it's not an easy life choice and it's
clear why most of us do eat meat one
because it's delicious and two because
it's just easy my life became very
cheese centric II I don't think it was
particularly healthy project for awesome
is happening again this year on December
17th and if you want you should
definitely already be working on ideas
for your cool videos promote charities
and our final topic of the day my face
here we have the results of the keep it
shaven foundation to decrease worldsuck
fundraiser and oh my god it was close a
shave it with 1440 $9.98
lose to the keep it's with 1494 dollars
and 43 cents
I wish it hadn't have been that close
now I feel like I'm betraying half a few
yeah I'm going to shave it at the end of
November we raised almost three thousand
dollars for the foundation to crease
worldsuck and a special thanks to Leanne
Spillane my high school English teacher
who donated $100 for me to keep it
without whom it would be being shaved
every vote counts people and when I say
vote of course mean dollar because
that's how America works I'm kidding
John this is the last part part 27 I'll
see you on Friday
I never think it was before it was
awesome